in the dying days of the 20th century
the modern library commissioned two
polls to find the greatest modern books
the first aimed at scholars returned
predictable results like the great
gatsby
but the second poll aimed at the general
public was a different story
the top of that list was occupied not by
fitzgerald or hemingway but by a russian
emigre
who arrived in america barely able to
speak english
and wrote only four novels all of which
were critical failures
yet from those few books einrand built a
philosophical edifice
which would inspire some of the most
powerful people in america
born alissa zinoviev no rosenbaum
ironrand's early life was marked by
non-stop catastrophe as a child in
russia she witnessed firsthand the
violence of the bolshevik revolution an
event
that left her with a lasting hatred of
socialism yet rand was
more than just an anti-communist a
radical believer in the individual she
embraced both a militant atheism
and a libertine lifestyle that was
shocking to her mid-century
contemporaries misunderstood in her
lifetime still controversial today
this is the life of iron rand america's
objectivist icon
at the moment ironrand first opened her
eyes on february the 2nd 1905.
it must have looked like fate had just
handed the new baby
the shortest of short straws the
daughter of a successful pharmacist rand
was born into a comfortable middle-class
home
in the grand city of some petersburg
then the capital of imperial russia
growing up the girl had servants nurses
and a mother who was positively
aristocratic
if you're wondering what's so short
straw about all of this though
you only have to look at rand's birth
name alyssa rosenbaum
as you can probably guess the rosen
bombs were jewish and sadly imperial
russia in 1905
had no time for jews for months the
country had been in the grip of the
worst anti-semitic violence in centuries
when rand was just eight months old her
parents received word that 2500 of their
co-religionists had been massacred
in the odessa pogrom it was entirely
possible
that they'd be next but violent
anti-semitism wasn't the only thing
threatening the rosenbaum's once stable
world 1905 was also
the year of the first russian revolution
when anger at a lack of domestic freedom
and getting staunch in a far away war
exploded into waves of unrest although
hurried reforms would leave the tsar
still standing the imperial system
had been badly strained all it would
take was one
more shove and the rotten edifice would
go crashing down
spoiler alert for russian history here
that shove was now
only 12 short years away not that the
young rand realized she was living
through the prologue to
a coming dystopia her childhood was both
dull and frustrating hampered by her
incredible intelligence and
even more incredible cynicism when her
teacher set an essay on the joys of
childhood rand instead wrote a screed
condemning childhood as
an intellectual wasteland perhaps it's
no surprise then to hear little inochka
spent
most of her free time alone absorbed in
books and movies
by 1914 aged just nine she had decided
she was going to be a writer but not
just one writing
in the russian tradition even as a child
randa hated the mysticism of her
homeland a
fact that would lead her to declare
herself an atheist at 13. but while
young and ran spent the mid-1910s
plugging away
churning out four novels about a
brilliant misunderstood pre-teen girl
the old religious russia she hated was
already on the verge of collapse
that summer 1914 imperial russia entered
world war one
although the tsar was on the winning
team his crumbling regime wouldn't make
it over the finish line by march of 1917
or february according to the julian
calendar still in use in russia at the
time
the war had so shattered the nation that
the capital
exploded in revolution number two for
twelve-year-old ayn rand the february
revolution was a thrilling time
she cheered from the sidelines as the
tsar's autocracy went down in flames
she cheered to the soft liberals who
came to power as the provisional
government she even expressed support
for
the moderate socialist alexander
karensky it was a brief flirtation with
the left
and it would certainly be her last eight
months later in october of 1917 karensky
and the provisional government were
overthrown
and replaced by lenin's bolsheviks it
was a pivotal moment in history one that
established the world's first
communist state it was also the moment
when the last traces of rand's
comfortable bourgeois life
vanished for good
while many russians were cautiously
optimistic about the bolsheviks rand
hated the new government from the get-go
not even age 13 she frequently spat
invective about lenin causing her family
to fear for her safety but this was
russia in 1917 everybody feared for
their safety when the civil war broke
out the rosenbaums fled to crimea to
escape the violence
there they lived in a desolate unheated
home for several years while
rand finished her schooling by now the
teenage rand was
sure of one thing that she hated
communism even more than she hated
religion but she hadn't yet found
anything
she loved any ideological framework she
could admire
as an alternative to socialism or sarism
that all changed
in her last year of high school taught
for the first time about the political
system in the united states
rand became convinced that america must
truly be the land of the free
but while she would eventually move
there she first had to deal with several
more years
in the land of the incredibly not free
in the early 1920s with the civil war
winding down the family returned to
saint petersburg
soon to be renamed leningrad so that
rand could study at university her
father had intended to resume his
business but the bolsheviks had
confiscated it
undeterred he tried to start over but
when his new business was likewise
confiscated
he declared he was on strike from then
on the rosenbaums would lead lives of
poverty and grinding hunger
still rand managed to continue her
studies but even in the closed-off world
of
college the chill winds of revolution
were still able to seep in
before ran's eyes the communist
government was clamping down
on freedom of thought on education on
everything
by the time she graduated in 1924 russia
was already on the slippery slope from
the police state of lenin
to the nightmare murder gulag of stalin
and it was clear aynrand wouldn't
survive this change
she was outspoken intelligent arrogant
she was vengeful and proud and insulting
although she was capable of being
charming when she wanted she refused to
cow toe to the guys with guns and gulags
if she stayed in russia it was clear
there was nothing in her future but a
late night knock at the door
and an anonymous grave somewhere in
siberia so in 1925 the rosenbaums agreed
for their daughter to go and stay with
relatives in america
for rand this was the dream come true
ever since that high school class she'd
idealized america with its industry
freedoms and mighty art deco skyscrapers
glowing like a thousand beacons
of course she couldn't tell the
bolsheviks this she told them she was
just going for a short trip that
she'll be back in no time but both ran
and her parents knew
that she'd never return the girl left
leningrad in early 1926 heading west
along a route traveled by
so many immigrants before her she turned
21 while passing through berlin and
celebrated by changing her name from
alyssa rosenbaum
to iron rand in later life she'd say
that the rand part came from her beloved
remington rand typewriter but
since remington rand wouldn't
incorporate for another year it's clear
this was a fabrication
by late february 1926 ironrand had
arrived in new york
although the site of america's greatest
city made her weep she
wouldn't stay there for very long her
first six months passed in chicago
just long enough to get the visa
extension she needed to secure her
future stateside and then it was off
west to the golden state to a magical
place
where dreams come true being rand was
going to go to hollywood
to say rand's life changed in hollywood
is to underestimate
just how head-spinning this
transformation was two days after
arriving the director cecil b demille
offered her first a lift in his car
then a job as a salaried extra and then
work as a script reader mere days later
she'd met and fallen in love with her
future husband frank o'connor
as a wise teenager once said life moves
pretty
fast but maybe not fast enough despite
landing on her feet rand would spend the
next few years
utterly failing at writing this wasn't
for lack of trying
she kept meticulous diaries including
making detailed notes on the serial
killer william hickman who
she called a man who really stands alone
in action
and in soul a brilliant unusual
exceptional boy
today we can see rand's obsession for a
forceful man like hickman as
a kind of early colonel for her future
characters in
terms of egoism at least but at the time
she was just an obscure immigrant
trying to catch a break it wouldn't come
easily although she managed to sell a
script to universal
her attempts at literature were
repeatedly shot down by editors who
called her characters stereotypes and
her themes obvious
still rand persevered in 1934 she staged
her first play
although given different names by
different theaters it's best known today
under its new york title the night of
january 16th
that's important because it was the
plays run in new york that convinced ran
to finally pack her bags
and leave the city that never sleeps the
move was all the inspiration she needed
rand landed a job at an architectural
firm and almost immediately began work
on a novel about an architect
if you know anything about rand you'll
already know that this book would become
the fountainhead her
breakthrough novel but it would take her
a long long time to finish
for now rand focused on producing a pair
of shorter novels that would be easier
to sell
waythe living was a
semi-autobiographical story about life
under the ussr that landed to mixed
reviews and
mild sales while anthem was a dystopian
sci-fi that was published to
an even weaker response still the two
books kept her going through those
lean times kept her going long enough to
finish her architecture novel
and find a publisher in 1943 the
fountainhead was finally released
friend ran and for millions of americans
it would change everything
if you only know rand for her politics
you might imagine the fountainhead
is an objectivist screed about an
unbridled superman repeatedly
punching the government in the testicles
but the novel is
really a story one that centers not on
rigid philosophy
but on universal themes its heart is
hard rock a visionary architect who
would rather destroy his own work
than see his vision compromised
surrounded by mediocrities
rorke's story is a man fighting to stay
true to himself as an artist and as a
human
but the fountainhead goes beyond just
rorke to
tap deep into american ideals there's
the glory of human achievement the
creativity rourke brings to people's
lives there's the excitement of
seeing rorke succeed not because he's
rich but because he's talented
unlike his rival peter keating only in
the game to
impress others basically it's a
celebration of hard work
artistry and being yourself all wrapped
up in a readable
if over long drama it's no wonder it
became a hit
although the fountain had first appeared
to mixed reviews and slow sales it
quickly became
a word of mouth success by the end of
the year it was big enough for rand to
sell the rights to hollywood with
herself attached as a screenwriter
nearly 20 years after arriving in
america the woman who'd once been
alyssa rosenbaum had made it she was
successful newly rich and
with a career ahead of her as a
best-selling writer and really
rand could have stopped there could have
rested on her laurels and kept turning
out books about passionate architects
but rand had bigger ideas weirder ideas
she didn't want to stop at fiction
she wanted to change the world in the
end rand didn't return to new york for
eight years
eight years during which she wrote the
screenplay for the fountainhead
watched it get turned into a mere film
and began to work on a final novel
but it wasn't all creativity in 1947
rand testified against her fellow
screenwriters
at the house on american activities
committee a witch hunt that inspired
arthur muller's the crucible while it
makes sense
in the context of rand's own experience
with communism it was still
a moral low point still the huac
appearance was a minor event in rand's
life
it would be a meeting in 1950 that had
the biggest impact on her future
that year rand started receiving fan
letters from a young ucla
student called nathaniel brandon 25
years rand's junior brandon nonetheless
seemed interesting enough
for rand to suggest they meet it was a
decision that would change both their
lives
brandon was blown away by rand's charm
and spiky personality
people later said that he staggered out
at their first meeting
like someone who had had a religious
experience for her part
rand was smitten at first she was just
seduced by brandon's admiration for her
but that seduction was about to get a
whole lot more literal
in 1951 brandon and his wife moved to
new york city
shortly after brand insisted to her
husband that they followed the pair to
the big apple although rand always
admired powerful men who dominated women
to the extent that the fountainhead
contains a sex scene that
wouldn't look out a place in 50 shades
in real
life she always called the shots so
o'connor dutifully followed her to the
city
and when rand announced in 1955 that she
was going to have an affair with brandon
o'connor didn't object at all
interestingly the affair didn't cause
any bad blood between rand and her
husband who
still doted on her what it did do was
provide rand
with an intellectual muse across the
1950s rand worked feverishly
on her book one speech alone took her
two years to write
the same time she and brandon expounded
on her growing philosophy
to a new circle of admirers night after
night people would congregate at rand's
new york apartment joining in debates
that lasted till morning debates
in which she developed her thoughts no
longer were her themes just the
unfettered individualism
and creativity of the fountainhead
working with brandon she was
constructing a whole edifice of thought
one that was strongly pro-capitalism
strongly anti-religion and
celebrated self-interest as humanity's
driving motor
these themes would profoundly shape her
final novel
released in 1957 atlas shrugged is a
tome the sort of book
you could easily use to give someone a
concussion the story of john gold who
leads the geniuses of the world on
strike it was both appeal to
individualism
and a heavy-handed allegory in which the
main characters spend 60 damn pages
spelling out the novel's themes if
you're watching this you probably
already have an opinion on it the world
of gold's gulch
is either a dream of rugged
individuality or a nightmare of
nietzsche and superman beholden to no
one
yet it's worth pointing out the novel is
more nuanced than its reputation
suggests yes
rand celebrates powerful wealthy
geniuses but she also celebrates blue
collar workers who bring
passion and experience to their jobs and
attacks rich parasites who do nothing
for their money
still it's not a novel you can call
subtle
that's sort of the point by 1957 brandon
and rand were actively building the
philosophy
they'd soon call objectivism atlas
shrugged would be its first
conscious expression good job it was a
phenomenal best seller although reviews
were so dismal that rand plunged into
depression
john galt wouldn't feel this she moped
to a diary
it made stacks of cash it also cemented
rand as one of the most influential
writers in america
[Music]
by the late 1950s rand and brandon were
working hard to get objectivism into the
mainstream
they published newsletters even open
schools in manhattan where brandon
spread the word the audience their
teachings found were young but
they'd grow to be hugely important
plenty of rand acolytes served in the
reagan administration most famously
alan greenspan chair of the federal
reserve ferand these were heavy times
she was so confident in a new philosophy
that she plowed
all her money and energy into it seeing
herself as on a mission
to save america from socialism she also
felt confident enough to
attack those who shared her goal but
preferred other methods they were the
early libertarians who
she dismissed as hippies scum and
plagiarists of her work
there was a religious right who she
denigrated as militant mystics unsuited
to power more damagingly she also turned
her poison pen
on her own followers where rand's
apartment had once been a space for
fierce intellectual battle
it was now a place for fawning students
to sit at her feet and
learn in reverential silence any hopeful
objectivists who disagreed with her on
anything would be cast out of the
movement as
would those who displeased her on some
personal level and rand
was about to be betrayed on the most
personal level imaginable
in 1968 rand discovered that brandon was
sleeping with another
younger woman although objectivists
should see this as brandon's moral right
to pursue his own happiness
that's not how rand saw it she expelled
her lover from objectivism shut down the
schools he'd opened
tried to have his writing career
sabotaged the blowout was so big that it
basically fractured her new movement
ending her stranglehold on objectivism
in the wake of the split
new groups with new interpretations of
rand's work sprang up across the country
much to the author's annoyance not that
there was anything she could do
in writing her novels rand had struck a
chord with millions of young people
across america
while that was great for sales it also
meant that there were now
uncountable people out there who had
formed their own ideas about john gold
and
wanted to take his teachings without all
the other objectivist crap
brands could either ride this wave of
feeling or she could fight against it
and be swept aside she settled for the
latter
post 1968 rand's personal influence
waned even as the influence of her
novels grew
it probably didn't help that her
physical health was giving out back in
1942 rand had started taking
amphetamines in
a rush to finish the fountainhead by the
late 1960s she had been addicted for
decades and that addiction was taking
its toll but it wouldn't be drug use
that put her out of the writing game
once and for all
but something far more tragic in the
early 1970s rand
was diagnosed with lung cancer although
a major operation saved her life it left
her exhausted and too weak to even
continue printing a newsletter
the medical bills also cleared her out
in the wake both she and her husband
were forced to apply for social security
benefits
while rand rationalized this as
restitution for the taxes that had been
stolen from her by the government
it was still a bitter pill for this
lifelong individualist to swallow but
even this
wasn't the worst thing to happen to her
that decade frank o'connor died on
november 9 1979.
although she'd carried on a multi-year
affair with brandon rand had always been
devoted to her husband
his death devastated her shattering
whatever spirit she had left
after that it was all downhill even as a
vowed fans of the fountainhead and atlas
shrugged descended to the highest levels
of government
even as objectivism took root on wall
street rand herself
seemed to fade from public life in one
of her last appearances
rand rallied against the new president
ronald reagan whose
courting of christians she despised it
was just another sign that
the times had moved on leaving her
behind modern conservatism had taken a
lot from
iron rand but it could survive quite
happily
without her einran died on march 6 1982
in a new york apartment
her only company a nurse at that moment
it was over a quarter century since
atlas shrugged had come out and
nearly 40 years since the success of the
fountainhead with objectivism no longer
a unified movement it must have seemed
like
she would soon be forgotten that her
relevance would quickly pass
but instead the opposite happened in the
years after her death sales of rand's
books only grew
by the late 1990s her work was selling
nearly as well as the bible in america
when the 2008 crash hit millions of
conservatives turned to her work
as a road map out of recession fast
forward to today and politicians actors
ceos and ex-presidents all proclaim
themselves
as fans of her work in many ways this
may well be
the perfect legacy for iron rand here
was a woman who was critically ignored
in her lifetime who struggled to make
any impression with the elites elites
who today
grew up reading the fountainhead and
learning of john gold
iran's story is many things the tale of
an escapee from soviet rule
of a traumatized immigrant who lived out
the american dream
but more than anything it's the tale of
a woman who did her best
to live life on her own terms she may
not quite have been one of her own
characters
but rand was certainly objectively
unique so i really hope you enjoyed that
video if you did please do hit that like
button
don't forget to subscribe and thank you
for watching